le président joe biden devait augmenter
la part de produits américaine achetée
par son gouvernement il en a fait une
priorité dans son discours sur l'état de
l'union prononcé hier joe biden a parlé
largement du conflit en ukraine mais il
a abordé aussi beaucoup d'enjeu de
politique intérieure il a promis que la
loi sur les infrastructures adopté
l'automne dernier serait utilisée pour
l'achat de produits et de matériaux
fabriqués aux états unis la loi consacre
1200 milliards de dollars américains à
la rénovation et à la construction de
ponts de routes de bornes pour véhicules
électriques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un
message assez clair du président bailly
donne avec nous ce soir martine hébert
la délégué général du québec à new york
bonsoir madame hébert
bonsoir est ce que vous avez entendu
hier un discours très protectionniste
absolument je pense que ton simple à
tous pour dire lequel il y avait
beaucoup de protectionnisme dans le
discours prononcé par monsieur by
dernière il ya eu une approche aussi
d'ailleurs avec des exemples très très
ciblée sur certains états qui seront
stratégiques le danger les élections de
mi mandat donc on voyait clairement que
l'objectif était clairement de dire à un
prix on veut avoir des chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui sont axées sur
le buy america sur les emplois
américains avec des entreprises
américaines c'est vraiment ce qu'on a
senti dans l'histoire prononce et ce
protectionnisme eux réaffirmé une
nouvelle fois people avec encore plus
d'ampleur présentement signifie quoi
pour les entreprises du québec qui
veulent faire des affaires aux états
unis bah écoutez c'est sûr que les
entreprises québécoises doit faire
preuve de résilience d'ailleurs
plusieurs d'entre elles ont déjà
adopté des stratégies qui leur
permettent de montrer un petit peu ses
élans protectionniste de la part
deux noms des clients américains on
pense par exemple à certaines
entreprises qui localise certains
certains aspects de leur production aux
états unis ont de vue dernièrement l'ont
encore une à une entreprise québécoise
technos trobe qui ont annoncé qu'ils
ouvraient une usine en albanie
d'assemblage de ses produits profiter
notamment les avantages qu'offre
l'éolien dans le territoire un new
yorkais donc c'est ce sont des
stratégies qui sont adoptés par
plusieurs vos joueurs québécois on a vu
les annonces dernièrement par lyon en
illinois on sait que nova bus est déjà
établie à plat d'hiver donc plusieurs
des bourgeois québécois leur viennent
installer certaines facile 10 je pense
que c'est important de dire j'ai rappelé
que c'est pas nécessairement mauvais
pour le québec non plus parce que les
contrats qui sont remportées par ces
entreprises le lot demeurent des
contrats signés par les maisons mères
qui elles sont privées et aussi ces
entreprises il demeure quand même avec
les sièges sociaux avec les centres de
recherche et développement au québec
souvent la clé centre d'ingénierie aussi
au québec qui sont effectivement les
emplois payants et donc des bons emplois
pour l'économie et donc dans le fond ce
que vous dites c'est le mieux qu'on peut
avoir puisque les américains veulent
tous fabriqués en sol américain allons
le fabriquer pour eux puis bon on
rapatrie une partie des revenus ou des
profits chez nous il peut y avoir un
impact mais cette idée d'avoir une
intégration continentale puis qui fait
en sorte qu'on a des usines au québec
puis partout au canada qui ont construit
toutes sortes de pièces on dirait que
c'est de moins en moins vrai martine
hébert ou en tout cas que les états unis
le veulent de moins en moins ben c'est
ce que le discours politique on le sent
de moins en moins comme quand tu parles
manufacturier hélas carmen kuhne
rillettes du terrain où une usine par
exemple qui fabrique des produits
électriques qui apporte certaines
composantes de fournisseurs québécois
avec ou sans changer sa ligne de
production djourou la mélo en criant
ciseau par d'isaba écoutez je vais
dorénavant produire ses composantes
l'homme ces pièces le moigne noble il
demeure quand même une réalité m
cette intégration loi elle est bien
présent et où l'on donne beaucoup
d'alliés pour continuer de la femme
parce que c'est important de continuer
assure une présence aux états unis pour
défendre les intérêts du québec en ce
sens là ils défendent les intérêts de
nos enfants mais quand joe budden 10 11
milliards investis par ford pour les
véhicules électriques
7 milliards investis par gm pour
fabriquer des véhicules électriques aux
états unis du début jusqu'à la fin elle
est où la place de la filière batterie
que le québec s est développée ben
écoute et un moment donné une réalité
qui est bien présente là pour faire des
batteries safran ça prend des minéraux a
appelé samedi lithium à prendre et ça
prend des mines et vos critiques et ces
minéraux critique là il y en a beaucoup
au québec à l'heure actuelle donc je
pense qu'une place pour le québec et
d'ailleurs ont fait une très forte
promotion de cette présence là de
minéraux critiqué stratégie que dans le
sol québécois auprès des investisseurs
américains parce que veut pas un jour où
l'autre va falloir s'approvisionner en
cellules de batterie pour fabriquer ses
batteries là et c'est celle de l'eau
sont composés des minéraux qui se trouve
chez nous alors je pense que l'on a été
ré a continué de faire valoir justement
ces aspects là et cette complémentarité
louer ce partenariat stratégique l'eau
qui occupe est important de maintenir
avec avec
jantes alliage que vous dites que healy
à ce discours politique surtout à
quelques mois des élections aux états
unis où on veut réaffirmer la
construction de fabrication en sol
américain mais dans la réalité les
américains n'ont pas le choix d'aller à
l'extérieur dans les semi-conducteurs
martine hébert sk une opportunité pour
le québec monsieur boyd on parlait d'un
tel le pdg d'intel étaient dans les
estrades ailleurs avec son usine de 20
milliards de dollars pour les semi
conducteurs
bekhti c'est sûr que les usines les
investissements sont dans des états qui
sont quand même près de l'économie
québécoise notamment en ohio donc on va
voir ce que seront les opportunités pour
le québec dans ces domaines là mais cela
étant dit c'est pas parceque refroidir
ils répondent par exemple d'opportunités
dans ce secteur la can a pas ailleurs et
ce qui est important de bien marquer
c'est que l'assiette des opportunités
pour les entreprises québécoises aux
états unis et les g elle est énorme elle
continue grandir et les lois pour les
dix prochaines années et c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'il faut continuer
d'avoir une présence de rallier de se
faire voir auprès de nous allier parce
que nous en avons des habitants chez les
élus que dans le milieu des affaires en
éviter il faut continuer que deux il
faut que le québec continue de faire
valoir son expertise l'expérience de ces
entreprises et le bénéfice mutuel de ce
partenariat
ça vous fait travailler fort en tout cas
martine hébert merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir on fait notre passé merci à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d